oh you know arresting me for some loony
that is claiming I hit him with the car
a 76 year old Florida man is arrested
and charged after allegedly slamming his
Porsche into a construction worker
directing traffic my random fun was like
yo I need you to stop he came to a
complete stop and I was like I need you
to stay right here and he started
throwing his hands up and then he
stepped on the gas and then like ran
into me on my legs and whatnot it had
November 3rd in Flagler County Florida a
portion of Camino Del Mar Parkway was
condensed to one lane of traffic as
other areas were being repaved
investigators say a driver went into the
single Lane when it wasn't his turn and
purposely ran into a worker
investigators Tracked Down the driver
and identified him as Donald steemull of
Ocala A black Porsche Cayenne was trying
to cut off the equipment and go around
them into the oncoming Lane because he
didn't want to wait body camera video
shows steemull telling officials he did
not hit the traffic worker yeah
foreign
right up to the car and hit the front of
the car
so that it wasn't your intention to hit
him of course
demo then says his car may have lunged
forward when the worker pressed down on
the vehicle's hood and he came right up
to me and I think he hit the car and he
said stop and the car might have moved
right there he was one I mean he was not
running fast but he was he was coming up
there like that he wanted the car and I
mean why would I run over somebody I
mean that's just as the conversation
continues steemell alleges the worker
noticed his high-end vehicle and made up
the story
somebody maybe is looking I'm driving a
nice car maybe taking advantage of the
situation there I can see if he just
claimed that we had no other Witnesses
but I mean the other Witnesses stories
were almost exactly the same and I spoke
to them you know separately the
responding Deputy then tells steamo
multiple Witnesses of the incident gave
this same story because I mean he's
claiming that he had you stopped and
then you revved your engine and went
into them and I have two witnesses also
corroborating that story when there
when the theory oh you're arresting me
for some Looney that is claiming I hit
him with the car
and he ran up put his hood on the car
put his hands on the car and there were
others other buddies were standing there
and probably and then he was swearing
cussing and
so you want to run you're gonna run me
over or something like that so so if you
wouldn't mind just putting your hands
out like that
foreign
you know what this is all about
steemall now faces charges of aggravated
battery with a deadly weapon the traffic
worker hit in the incident reportedly
sustained minor injuries for the latest
developments in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie